[crowd noise]
[singing: "Sednalo e Djore Dos"]
SUZIE SHOFFNER:
There are 89 students.
ALEXANDRA GREEN:
And 12 students pursuing a
certificate in musical performance.
NATHANIEL FLEMING:
We're from 23 states.
ALEXANDRA CERF:
And 18 countries.
DAVID SIMINS:
19 tenors.
JOHN WHELCHEL:
24 basses.
DAVID HWANG:
24 sopranos.
KATIE WELSH:
22 altos.
KRISTAN SCOTT:
23 majors.
EMI NAKAMURA:
And pursuing 32 different certificates.
ALL:
88 new friends.
[singing]
GABRIEL CROUCH:
Do I sing, as well?
I sing during rehearsal all the time.
I try to join in every part,
as well, if I possibly can.
You know, obviously, bass and
tenor are sort of easy, but the
sopranos will tell you that I have this
squealy falsetto voice.
[singing, laughter]
I do still sing in my spare time, as well.
Before I came here, I was actually a
professional singer.
You know, I came here because
I wanted to do this instead.
ARYEH NUSSBAUM COHEN:
To have the opportunity to sing under
a conductor who cares so deeply
about each and every
individual in the choir, and
every moment of music that we
make, is really, really inspiring.
EMILY SUNG:
I always learn something new from rehearsal.
Not just one new thing, but many, many new things.
He manages to be interesting
for two hours at a time,
without a break.
And so people watch him and
they really pay attention.
NATHANIEL FLEMING:
For those two hours, you're able to
immerse yourself in something
else, and something that you
all have in common.
That experience makes it much more fun.
[singing]
GABRIEL CROUCH:
The only thing that you really need to do to
be in Glee Club is to have some
experience of reading music.
EMILY SUNG:
We only have seven music majors,
which I think is a testament
to how possible it is to
participate in music here, even
if you don't want to turn
it into the focus of your life.
[singing]